si de hecho el departamento de justicia
le estaba pidiendo a este pues que no
diera ese visto bueno para que se
conociera le dé un poco de contexto los
periodistas son los que han pedido a
este juez de la justicia estadounidense
que se conocieran más detalles sobre
esta orden jurídica precisamente para
conocer pues detalles de qué fue lo que
llevó a la justificación que tuvo el fbi
para allanar la mansión de mar a lago en
la florida del expresidente de donald
trump y en esta justicia en el en esta
en esta orden lo que los periodistas
quieren conocer precisamente son
detalles de lo que se encontró detalles
de
quiénes eran los testigos que dieron
información sobre lo que había en estas
estas cajas y en estos documentos
secretos y entonces lo que argumenta la
corte el perdón en el departamento de
justicia a eeuu es que de publicarse
mañana a mediodía estos documentos
podría poner precisamente en riesgo
testigos y el jurado y la estrategia de
investigación que tiene el fbi
precisamente para llegar a fondo a la
información que tiene el presidente el
ex presidente de otros pisos humanos y
no ha querido devolver hay que mencionar
que hace un año archivo nacional está
pidiendo esta información al ex
presidente camps y el presidente de
trump ha tomado varios caminos para no
entregarla en total son 700 documentos
que le pide archivos nacionales al ex
presidente don otro y hasta ahora
solamente ha entregado 300 documentos